[Música]
colombia tiene un nuevo presidente con
el
54% de los votos fue elegido el
izquierdista gustavo petro y su
compañera de fórmula la lidereza afro
francia márquez frente a su rival
rodolfo hernández y su compañera marilyn
castillo quienes consiguieron el 47 por
ciento de los votos
líderes de américa latina especialmente
de izquierda saludaron la victoria de
gustavo petro en colombia mandatarios
como gabriel boric de chile hablaron
sobre la unidad del continente mientras
que los de venezuela y méxico
calificaron el resultado como histórico
en francia se complica la gobernabilidad
de manuel macro no perdió la mayoría
absoluta que su partido tenía en la
cámara baja del parlamento lo que lo
obligará a buscar alianzas la izquierda
queda como segunda fuerza tenemos
reporte desde parís
hola bienvenidos a una nueva emisión de
noticias en france 24 los saluda andrés
meza muñoz iniciamos en colombia porque
el país tiene nuevo presidente el
primero de izquierda en la historia
democrática colombiana con el 50,4 por
ciento de los votos fue elegido el
izquierdista gustavo petro y su
compañera de fórmula la de la lidereza
afro francia márquez frente a su rival
rodolfo hernández y su compañera marilyn
castillo quienes consiguieron el
47,3 por ciento de los votos tras
conocer los resultados del preconteo el
nuevo presidente electo dio un discurso
donde anunció que llegó el gobierno de
la esperanza para todos y todas las
colombianas el la esperanza
el cambio significa que esa esperanza
puede hacer y llenar todos los rincones
del territorio nacional
que la esperanza reine en el corazón el
cambio significa que llegó el gobierno
de la esperanza también evocó la
importancia de la paz en el país gustavo
petro defendió durante toda su campaña
los acuerdos de paz firmados en 2016
entre el gobierno del entonces
presidente juan manuel santos y la ahora
extinta guerrilla de las farc
el gran acuerdo nacional es para
construir la paz y la paz no es más que
la garantía de los derechos de la gente
la paz
es que la sociedad colombiana
tenga oportunidades
la paz es que alguien como yo pueda ser
presidente o alguien como francia pueda
ser vicepresidenta
la paz
es que dejemos de matarnos los unos a
los otros
tras la victoria en la segunda vuelta de
las elecciones presidenciales de
colombia el izquierdista gustavo petro
los mandatarios de los diferentes países
latinoamericanos reaccionaron al triunfo
con la llegada del candidato del pacto
histórico a la presidencia en agosto de
américa latina tendrá una decena de
presidentes izquierdistas manuel a cano
con los detalles te quiero mucho en
colombia triunfo de la izquierda
el candidato del pacto histórico gustavo
petro ganó la segunda vuelta
presidencial con 50 como 4% de los votos
y las reacciones de los dirigentes
latinoamericanos llegaron de norte a sur
con una alusión a la literatura
colombiana el presidente mexicano andrés
manuel lópez obrador celebró la victoria
el triunfo de gustavo petro es histórico
los conservadores de colombia siempre
han sido tenaces y duros el escritor
josé maría vargas vila relataba que los
dictadores de su país mojaban en agua
bendita su puñal antes de matar
desde honduras la presidenta xiomara
castró felicitó al pueblo colombiano en
nombre del pueblo de honduras felicitó
al valiente pueblo de colombia por
elegir el histórico cambio social que
representa hoy el presidente electo
gustavo petro suramérica también se
llenó de reacciones el mandatario
venezolano nicolás maduro reconoció el
triunfo de petró desde el país vecino
felicitó a gustavo petro ya france a
márquez por la histórica victoria en las
elecciones presidenciales en colombia se
escuchó la voluntad del pueblo
colombiano que salió a defender el
camino de la democracia y la paz
y desde la frontera occidental lo hizo
el presidente ecuatoriano guillermo
lasso ha felicitado telefónicamente ha
gustado petro por su elección como
presidente de nuestra hermana república
de colombia y reitere la disposición de
nuestro gobierno para fortalecer la
amistad y cooperación priorizando el
desarrollo y la integración de nuestros
pueblos también aplaudió la victoria de
petró el más reciente presidente
izquierda de la región gabriel boric
acabo de hablar con gustavo petro para
felicitarlo por su triunfo en la
presidencia de colombia junto a francia
márquez alegría para américa latina
haremos juntos por la unidad de nuestro
continente en los desafíos de un mundo
que cambia velozmente seguimos con el
triunfo de petró américa latina' da un
paso más hacia la izquierda con una
decena de mandatarios que comparten
dicha ideología por su parte rodolfo
hernández el magnate colombiano de la
construcción reconoció la derrota dice
que espera que la decisión de los
colombianos sea la mejor y pidió a
gustavo petro que no defraude a sus
electores como le expresa y
reiteradamente
aceptó el resultado como debe ser si
deseamos que nuestras instituciones sean
firmes
sinceramente espero que esta decisión
que ha tomado sea beneficiosa para todos
y que colombia se encamina hacia el
cambio que previno en el voto de la
primera vuelta le deseó al doctor
gustavo petro que sepa dirigir el país
que sea fiel a su discurso contra la
corrupción y que no defraude a quienes
confiaron en él cambiamos de tema y
vamos a francia donde también hubo
segunda vuelta de las elecciones
legislativas con malas noticias para el
presidente manuel macro de acuerdo con
las estimaciones de ipsos sobras esther
y el mandatario perdió la mayoría
absoluta que tenía en la asamblea
nacional lo que lo va a forzar a aliarse
con partidos como los republicanos de
corte conservador desde parís nuestra
periodista erika olavarría con los
detalles
nunca la asamblea nacional francesa
había conocido una configuración
semejante y esto representa un riesgo
para nuestro país dada las
circunstancias internas y externas que
enfrenta así reaccionó la primera
ministra francesa elisabeth von a los
resultados de esta segunda vuelta de las
legislativas en este país recordemos que
el gobierno de manuel macro ni la
coalición de partidos que le apoya ha
perdido la mayoría absoluta en la
asamblea nacional está derrota en cambio
fue vivida como una victoria por sus dos
principales oponentes políticos de una
parte de la coalición de izquierda a la
nubes liderada por jean luc mélenchon
que si bien no logra elegirlo como
primer ministro si se convierte en la
primera fuerza de oposición al gobierno
y también por el partido de extrema
derecha agrupación nacional de marine le
pen queda la sorpresa esta noche sin
duda al obtener casi 80 asientos en la
futura asamblea nacional cuando las
encuestas vaticinaban mucho menos además
el gobierno debe afrontar la derrota de
varios macro nistas de mi inicio como
christoph acá están el presidente del
grupo de la república en marcha la
asamblea nacional y del pro presidente
de la asamblea nacional richard pegaron
también la derrota de varios de sus
ministros que de acuerdo a un acuerdo
tácito en el gobierno deberán dejar sus
cargos como la ministra de transición
ecológica a melide emotional o la
ministra de salud derrotada en el norte
de francia ahora la gran duda es cómo va
a ser el gobierno de manuel macrón para
llevar adelante los proyectos más
urgentes como el del poder adquisitivo
de los franceses para aumentarlo o más
polémicos como la reforma de las
jubilaciones que viene del quinquenio
anterior lo más probable aparece una
alianza con la derecha que si bien no
tiene muchos menos asientos que en
administraciones anteriores sigue
teniendo un peso suficiente para
mostrarse como una fuerza de negociación
con las distintas mayorías que estarán
presentes en esta asamblea nacional
eeuu celebró este 19 de junio el yum
team que conmemora el fin de la
esclavitud en este país fue reconocido a
nivel federal el 17 de junio de 2021
luego de que el presidente joe biden
firmara un proyecto de ley que así lo
establecía los festejos se extendieron a
lo largo del fin de semana
detalles en el siguiente informe de
ariana villacorta
es el segundo de un 15 en la historia de
eeuu una fiesta federal que conmemora el
fin de la esclavitud legal de los
afroamericanos en este país decenas de
personas tomaron las calles de galveston
texas epicentro de las celebraciones ya
que fue en esta ciudad donde se originó
este movimiento
realmente significa mucho para mi
aprecio de este día y todos los días que
siguen a este y que vinieron antes por
lo que pasaron muchos de mis antepasados
y los que se conocieron y la lucha que
hicieron por nosotros
en otras ciudades del país como nueva
yersey y nueva york las celebraciones
fueron reemplazadas por protestas los
manifestantes exigieron reparaciones
para los afroamericanos ya que el
gobierno federal de eeuu nunca ha pagado
ninguna indemnización a los
descendientes de las personas
esclavizadas así como tampoco ha emitido
una disculpa formal
es hora de que nosotros la gente de
color la gente negra cuyos descendientes
llegaron aquí en barcos de esclavos en
1619 que ayudaron a construir este país
obtengamos reparaciones
de acuerdo con william de hariri júnior
profesor de política pública y estudios
afroamericanos de la universidad de duke
el 30 por ciento de los estadounidenses
blancos parecen respaldar las
reparaciones como pagos monetarios a los
estadounidenses afroamericanos mientras
que otros 30 por ciento es recalcitrante
respecto a cualquier propuesta política
que mejore la condición de esta minoría
hasta aquí es informativo gracias por
acompañarnos
[Música]